[Musik]
die löhne zu bieten berge ein barocken
stadtkerns eine stolze mittelalterliche
festung eine der bekanntesten österreich
[Musik]
denn ihn gibt euch ein paket wurde die
salzburger gern aufhalten
[Musik]
und mein
das ist jetzt mein favorit cacau hier in
mozarts wohnhaus gibson des café classic
das wissen viele gar nicht berührt vom
platz für die salzburger ganz gern
hingehen ich auch in der ersten etage
des wohnhauses stehen die musealen
kostbarkeiten die paten anschlagen darf
man nur mit erlaubnis das ist jetzt das
alte hammerklavier der familie mozart
wolfgang hat selber auch drauf gespielt
die steingasse die zurück
weitgehend unbekannt dabei gehört sie
zum ethischen salzburg kärnten häuser
entstanden hier bereits im ersten
jahrhundert jede markante einkerbung ist
ihr auch wesentlich jünger nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg entstanden als die
amerikaner hier in salzburg waren und
die idee junge soldaten haben versucht
in diese gastel mit seinem klein
panzerglas rein zu fahren weil da hinten
dran interessante damen und sie hatten
leider schon ein paar bierchen getrunken
und sind dann festgefahrenen martin auch
hin wieder ausziehen müssen die
salzburger haben das so witzig gefunden
das sind jetzt diese spur einfach
gelassen haben
die salzburger erfreuen sich nicht nur
an ihrer geschichte zunächst als bauwerk
und stritten wie das museum der modernen
seit 2004 jährlich tausende besucher an
[Musik]
die lage natürlich fantastisch hier oben
anschaut über die stadt und dann ist es
wahnsinnig wichtig für mein gefühl dass
wir auch so wie sie es überhaupt halte
traditionelle auch neue dinge am und das
museum ist natürlich genau der platz das
hier so n 32 im museumsgebäude könnt ihr
dann den tag in salzburg entspannt
ausklingen lassen